mardi matin sur France 2 pas pendji le
ministre de l'éducation nationale a
abordé le sujet tabou il y a encore
quelques mois du port des abayas c'est
longrobe islamique portée par les filles
et des camis portés par les garçons
début février plusieurs académies
avaient relevé la multiplication du port
de ses tenues religieuses or une loi de
2004 interdit le port de signe religieux
ostentatoire par les élèves et les
enseignants à l'intérieur des
établissements scolaires une note du
comité interministériel de prévention de
la délinquance et de la radicalisation
révélée en août par l'hebdomadaire
L'Express faisait état d'une
recrudescence de discours islamistes sur
les réseaux sociaux remettant en cause
la loi de 2004 et le principe de laïcité
à l'école pire selon la note l'agitation
numérique rappelle les mécanismes ayant
mené à l'assassinat de Samuel Paty le
professeur décapité a
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine à la sortie de
son collège en 2020 entre décembre 2021
et mars 22 les ports de signes est
tenues représentaient les atteintes les
plus fréquentes à 22% en hausse de 7
points par rapport aux précédents bilan
et des incidents concernant un refus de
retirer un vêtement religieux ce sont
multipliés mais ces statistiques
pourraient être plus élevées car elles
sont basées sur les signalements des
chefs d'établissement dont beaucoup font
peu remonter les incidences car le sujet
est Abou en septembre le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale invitait les
recteurs à la vigilance évoquant
clairement la Bahia et le kamis mais
selon indépendance et direction Force
Ouvrière deuxième syndicat des
personnels de direction l'alerte n'a pas
été suivi des faits dans les académies